if you've seen any of the thor ragnarok
trailers then you'll know that as god
has a new villain who goes by the name
of hella but who is she and where did
she come from in Norse mythology hell is
the daughter of Loki making her the
sister of both Fenrir and young meg and
all of Loki's children were eventually
banished from Asgard
and hell was no exception shortly after
her birth she was banished by Odin to
hell more commonly known as the realm of
Helheim where the dead reside she made
Helheim her kingdom where she would rule
over the dead and the banished as the
goddess of the underworld hell's task
was to determine the fate of those who
entered the realm of the dead those who
died in battle would not be sent to hell
instead they went to Valhalla her
appearance is described as being half
black half white with a perpetual brim
and fierce expression on her face the
Vikings believed Hell to be half dead
and half alive and are often fearful of
her the German barbarians viewed hel as
having two sides light and dark being
helpful in times of need and vengeful to
those who cross her the most common
depiction of Hell is that of a greedy
and cruel leader indifferent to the
concerns of both the living and the dead
unfortunately Hellas character is not
mentioned much in Old Norse literature
and she's normally mentioned only in
passing one of the early surviving myths
to feature hell in detail is the death
of Balder the beloved Balder had been
slain by Loki and as a result was sent
to hell
upon arriving in Helheim the gods
emissary explained to hell that every
living thing was in mourning because of
the death of Baal dear she agreed to
release Balder
if every living thing in the universe
shed a tear for him there was one giant
who refused to shed a tear presumed to
be Loki in disguise because of that one
refusal her terms were not met and she
decided to keep Boulder in the
underworld from this story we can see
that Heather's character is similar to
that of her father's with not much known
about the character it'll be interesting
to see what direction mod will take with
her and what aspects of Norse mythology
they keep if you've enjoyed this video
then please go ahead and leave it a like
consider subscribing if folklore
mythology is something that interests
you if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained